I mean first of all and just so we put
it as straight on the table you know the
reason i'm not talking about my own
reason but President Bush's reason for
going into Iraq was not religion I mean
it wasn't religion right now you may be
the wrong decision but it wasn't
religiously based and one of the single
biggest difficulties we have in this
space is where people end up with a
continual sense of a sort of conspiracy
theory around decision making that's
done rather than simply recognizing when
you were in a political position and
you're a you're a leader you know you
take decisions now there may be the
right decisions there may be the wrong
decisions but I can't think myself of a
situation in a liberal democracy in
which a leader has taken a major
decision based simply on his religious
belief you know my religion impels me to
do this I can't think of a situation
which that's happened and you're right
in the sense that some there are but
religious people who don't want religion
to enter the public space because they
fear you know what the consequences of
that may be but I actually think it's
you know this this issue to do with
religion and liberal democracy I think
liberal democracy itself is the biggest
discipline actually on people for
religious reasons in positions of power
doing things just simply on the basis of
their religious faith it's a far bigger
danger frankly that type of thinking in
situations where you get an undemocratic
system because then there's no check by
the people on what the the leaders
actually doing so you know I look I
think ultimately you you are always look
altima tlie if there are people in
positions of authority who are of
religious faith it is an absurdity to
think their faith does not give the
it's not part of their character but
it's in the nature of our types of
society that actually the the the
numbers of people who will ever be in a
position of power where they literally
say right I'm doing this this is not a
policy judgment I'm making all this is
not about the interest in my country I'm
just doing this because I'm religiously
impelled to do it I can't as I say I
can't think on a major decision I can't
think of an example certainly from here
or from Europe where that so so I think
we're going to be careful of you know
seeing seeing sort of threats or fears
that are that aren't there I think what
is a far bigger fear actually is this
notion of religion as an exclusive claim
in opposition to others but I honestly
think you're not finding that
predominantly in the West today